what's up this your boy rmc mike man
check me out on the bootleg care podcast
all right bootleg cat podcast special
guest in here
from flint yes sir
rmc mike yes sir welcome man how you
doing i'm all right man glad to be here
i'm greg glad to have you man
shout out to flint man yeah sir anyone
knows stand up uh we i gotta ask i'm
gonna be probably visiting flynn shortly
what is the water situation getting
close to getting sorted out yet
listen man you want my disability we
went through obama
to trump and now we're back to the obama
administration biden's in there [__]
what's going on with the water you won't
mind as a people yes
i feel like this [__] was a big scale
yeah i swear to god
cause it wasn't it wasn't nothing really
wrong with the water bros the pipes for
real
so what
so what is this we broke [__] y'all
late for this fix all these goddamn
pipes
but then again i'm just putting like
this
i don't know
i don't know no one
personally that's been affected by it so
you don't know anybody who's actually
had any sort of like direct effects from
the bad ones so i'm like i still drink
the [__] bro i make noodles with the
[__] i make kool-aid with the [__]
so you don't get the bottled water
you're actually
sink
are you worried that like the side
effects might not be like maybe 20 years
from now you might
get like a tumor or something
it is what it is at that point
20 years from now should be super rich
you'll be able to get that thing cut out
figure it out have you thought about
getting the burrito
with the filter in your fridge that you
just pour it's like the little like
handle thing it's got a filter you
burrito it you know like i never seen it
honestly
so you're just [__] you're free
balling the water and flint [__] you i
love it
that's amazing might as well uh man you
you and uh rio been doing your thing bro
obviously free rio uh but you guys have
been um
just on a tear independently
for a minute just putting on for the
city um how's he doing how's his spirits
oh he's good see that's one thing about
reid he always i experienced no matter
the situation so it was like
he good man he you know he don't like he
one of them personal people that don't
like to see he don't want to know
he's not going to let you know he
worried about anything right
you're a leader
what's uh what's like the status with
him anyway as far as like when is he
going to be getting out like
so originally
you know he was he was sentenced to five
years
but you know i out of fears go
so we dinner was looking at like what
three and a half
and maybe we can be even sooner you
never know because you know they lost
change every day they got programs and
[__] like that so i'm hoping they you
know they just said that the house of
representatives like uh
passed the
idea of taking weed off of the federal
like list you know because it's
federally like still it's still in the
same category as like cocaine and
you know in michigan you they got it's
recreational now right right
but
everywhere is still federally illegal so
um hopefully when that happens they're
just going to let a ton of [__]
[__] out of jail yeah you would
hope so oh so go ahead and let my baby
out man need a superstar uh what is
going on with you man uh your manager
was just feeling i didn't know you're so
you're into race cars yeah what like
when you say race cars what kind of race
cars like
like driving like i got me and my pops
got a real drag like like a like the
long one no we got a i got we got a 93
5.0 mustang oh that's a classic car
right there yeah you know what i said we
got a drink
parachute all that [__] it's got a
parachute on it
yeah
5.0 back in the like that's
my cousin had a friend some horses in
this mustang [__] your scaredy pack oh
my god so what got you was it your pops
that got you into that yeah i was really
bored into it so your dad was always a
car guy oh he like him and his side of
the family was like they all was in
automotive field they all worked at gm
delphi
chrysler right you know what i'm saying
so it was just like
literally something i was born into
they say that back in the day
in flint if you drove a japanese car
people used to give you [__] for it i
could believe that
like back back when like it was all the
american car factory with the motor city
you know the yeah city put it that way
excuse me we're the vehicle city
but you know like
i was even so like back in the 50s the
40s 50s 60s like flint was one of the
popping
like states like i heard that we had the
biggest manufacturer mm-hmm you know
what i'm saying gm all that so it was
like it was big back then but
a lot of [__]
yeah
the crack air hit
and just
jobs moving out of the office factory's
closing
you know yeah for sure like uh what's um
for you and and uh the racing thing like
how hands on are you with with can you
like are you like a mechanic loki so
what i just learned i learned everything
i know from my pops though you know what
i'll say because he didn't know all a
lot he's so if you have a car and some
[__] goes wrong
and then like that but like something
breaking so we fish like we drive we
pull them out and drop the motor back in
you ought to do it like all the
mechanics no that's serious
you can swap out a fuel pump yeah we can
do that
someone's catalytic converter gets
stolen can you put a new one in yeah we
can do that the catalytic converter
thing is crazy right now no for sure
especially where i'm from what is it why
is it so expensive is it because of what
it's made of yeah that's exactly why
it's so expensive because i'm like man
the catalytic
converter hustle is crazy right now like
people really are out here snatching
going up can you imagine like that's
like your grind you're like yo we're
running around finding catalytic
converters today
and trust me the people out here that
was doing that and still own it you
low-key gotta be like a mechanic to be a
thief for that i don't know for sure you
gotta be like cause there's some
crackheads out here who could
look at the problems
hidden talents for sure
it's crazy because like for the longest
time uh
was it it was m.c breed was from flint
right
and then uh
i'm trying john connor
john connors uh who he you know he was
on shady for a little bit uh what was it
aftermath
one of them too um
why do you think like kind of the the
stars are finally aligning for flint and
even for that matter just like michigan
as a whole i feel like is just on fire
right now like the [__] is booming
honestly
i feel like we played a big part in that
because it's like
john caught in them did they thing
did they die you know so they put out
for
flint but for some reason this [__] just
ain't like kids global like that
well i don't know because you know i'm
still kind of young so i'm 28 right
so i know just for me with my knowledge
it just didn't crack globally like me
and real damned or did right right right
right right like this [__] damn they're
good
global you guys are doing serious
numbers
i'm assuming like you guys are probably
close to getting some independent
plaques at this point oh no for sure but
it was like
i don't know i just feel like we brought
a whole new sound to the game that it
made it just so big it made it a little
bit more bigger
i stopped you know yeah but the michigan
as a whole is going crazy right now you
know detroit bailed michigan down for
years man we fight we giving them some
help it feels like um
everyone's a lot more unified
than they were maybe five years ago
definitely coming around because before
i feel like detroit was like a bunch of
like different scenes in one city
or just michigan like you had like
eminem and royce and like more the
lyrical [__] slum village like
uh then you had like insane clown posse
which was like white trash [__]
shout out to the juggalos and then you
had like
you know dope boys cash out uh the more
street [__] but i felt like the street
[__] never really
kind of prospered because it felt like
there was just so much division
but it feels like everyone's kind of
moving in the same direction now for the
most part you know yeah
good you gotta think about it
it's just way more the street rappers
are
away everybody this is way more street
rappers than it is
other type of stuff
like there's a lot of [__] that's a lot
of talent
there's a lot of talent coming out today
right now even flint like a lot of
people unknown that i don't even know
that you really are like that who are
some of the artists in flint man that
you think are our next steps it's a lot
man
it's a lot for sure
you know i'm saying it's the name of
cover but
like
boy king cash is like he's serious
if y'all like that y'all could look him
up on all these things
here but
he called like that yeah
it's a lie we got baby ghosts
[Music]
like
oh no it's a lot of people it's a lot of
people rapping bro i can't i can really
can't name them all
don't be mad it's just so many of y'all
i can't you know what i'm saying yeah
express everybody say everybody
but i'm just saying flip work
what is the event that you're putting
together in in like kind of surrounding
the race car [__]
so
my manager my manager came up with this
brilliant idea for real
she know the girl i mean big with the
music she know i like cars you know so
she just like why don't we put together
like a uh event at the race car track
you know what i'm saying like bring all
the racers down there
you know it can be
wouldn't be
big with the marijuana so
we can just combine all this [__]
together and just make one big show
weed race cars rap music rap music
it all ties into each other
yeah i mean officially
don't drive while high though no for
sure but
it all ties into each other are you
gonna like like let me so having a race
car is a lot different than racing a
race car you being that [__]
like racing no
because you could own a race car and
like have
now let me tell you though i bought my
first old school
mm-hmm what what kind of car yeah i got
a 86 money assist oh [__] that's classic
i was when i first bought it that's what
i was i was going to do the big round
race you know that's a that's the thing
doc man fact you call that an old school
when i was born in 87 just makes me feel
oh [__] this old school's gonna be
forever being closed when you say old
school i'm thinking 60s 70s i ain't
going back i'm old as [__] i'm old
school like what i was growing up you
know there was a 36 year old car
box chevy's and monte carlos
no the monte carlo i mean the 86 monte
carlo super sport that's a that's a
classic car yeah see i want a 79
i want a 79
yeah money color
training day
that is the training day car
live money girl beautiful
that's your gold car
eventually no my go-kart is a is is a
i want a grand national if i can ever
get my hands
you know what's dope about those cars is
they're like truly investments no for
sure like if you get like a g wagon like
it's cool but like
anyone can get a g wagon i got a cool
story about a grenade
what is your story
my cousin bought a grand national mm-hmm
if i tell you
for the love like for real this is what
he did
he bought a grand national you know it
was stock v6 turbo
so what he did was
he just basically put bigger pipes on
the turbo
so i can breathe more yep
hawaii took it to the racetrack
put it in the shootout and he came
second
with a v6
wow
are you wearing money
did second place get to back second
place
with a v6 with a v6
in in in uh i'm talking about stock
though like all he did was just say oh
god put the pipes on it all he did was
put bigger pipes on his hook and breathe
do you know what car he raced
when he raced a couple cars it wasn't
like a big huge shootout i think it was
only probably like a six car shootout
shootout is a race just so people so we
just we're clear yeah the shootout is a
race basically like it's six cars to
enter yeah so he pulled second even
though he only had a stock the stock
grand national yep that's crazy yeah i
feel like more rappers should get into
old schools because they are like
literally
a commodity
because
if [__] go hits the fan like you just
said
i'm sure if a grand national is rightly
available at a car lot you would already
have one
those cars are hard to come by they are
good was that the good ones that aren't
[__] up that aren't rusted they don't
beat the [__]
dude don't let no don't let them know
what they got
yeah
you kind of want to find somebody who
doesn't really know what it is it's kind
of like oh that was i don't know that
was just grandpa's car you know what uh
i'll tell you what i could do that's
what i could do
you know if he's somebody who got he
gonna take he's gonna crack you upside
the head for sure for sure for sure uh i
saw you just put out uh uh in march you
put out a l it was a la freestyle yeah
yeah um
did you record that out here
yeah i'd assume so i did honestly i
recorded it out here
um what is coming up in 2022
uh a lot more music i'm finna get your a
lot more music you're going definitely
yeah get hopefully gonna get senior
season this year okay yeah cause you got
the junior season i mean you kind of
started with rookie
we've taken us through the whole i was
gonna say you've taken us through the
whole uh
so senior season is coming this year
what happens after that by the way is it
like graduation or what are we doing
here that's crazy because i was going to
call it graduation day yeah [__]
go with the graduation day yeah yeah i
like that graduation day would be hard
i like that graduation day
but it's like
you're complaining about here oh i'm
trying to see we we looking at the next
level now
it was like about by the time that come
on i'm trying to damn there be rocking
with the big leagues somewhere
at least like
got some type of big
features so with bigger artists you know
[__] like that like that's coming right
who do you want to work with though like
if you had to you know
industry-wise yeah like if you you just
said bigger features like who who in
your opinion is somebody would like to
like
like i said i always want to work with
no cat
no cap's crazy uh
like i'm a big no cab catfish
he's fired him rallo brothers
right there is serious those feel
extremely realistic
realistic i mean like those are gonna
happen for you if you want them to
happen i'm sure
[Music]
melodic kind of
alternative i'll [__] wit him on it
cause i got
i'ma put it like this i just became a
trippy fan when
he he had a show in detroit and he
personally invited me in real
backspace his live shows are crazy right
oh my god i ain't never seen yourself
rock [__] it's like some rock star [__]
man no for real like i learned what the
my spirit was and everything like i
ain't know what the [__] this [__] was
but i'm like and then it made me like
just going to his show it made me really
tune into his music like troopy really
hard he got some bangs he's fired fire
trippy rallo
no cap
i like that
that's uh that's
[Music]
what's up y'all we got to stop the
interview real quick to tell you about
our good folks at bluechew.com
fellas
when it's time to get that [__] going
you know what i'm saying when it's time
to hit the sack with a young lady you
need that confidence
trust me maybe you had a bad day maybe
your anxiety's through the roof your
stress well that could [__] up
everything when it comes time for you to
get down you know what i'm saying with a
young lady or a young man whatever
you're into uh well young etc whatever
you like you know what i'm saying listen
bluechu.com is to the rescue bluechu is
a unique online service it delivers the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis but in a chewable form at a
fraction of the cost and it's fire it
works trust me bluetooth tablets they
help men achieve harder stronger [__]
stronger erections
and it combats all forms of ed all right
that's right
if you're feeling a little uh like ah
man [__] ain't been right down there
listen that blue chew come to the rescue
get your dick right but all right trust
me when i say it hey listen bluetooth
it's an online prescription service it's
the best part there's no weird awkward
visits awkward conversations at the
doctor's office none of that it ships
right to your door in a discrete package
all right it's super simple go to
bluetooth.com you can consult with one
of their medical providers uh and then
once you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days and it's all
online all right that's right
and uh the best part is you can go to
bluechew.com right now use my promo code
bootleg at checkout that's use the promo
code bootleg at checkout and you're
gonna get your first month of blue chew
for free
just five dollars shipping trust me when
i say
this [__] is lit all right i love blue
chew
maybe you're married
maybe you uh
just going through it at work and you
just feel like you need that extra
little boost that extra confidence man
edie hits a lot of men in different ways
you know what i'm saying that blue chew
will have your dick right my g
bowman
thor's hammer
bluechu.com
get your first month for free with the
promo code bootleg asap go do that um
what for you like staying independent
how important is that because i mean i'm
sure
at any given time there's been
opportunities to go to a major to you
know it's it's big to stay independent
man i just feel like independent that
that way
to go not saying that i i'm putting like
this too
i'm somebody who really cared for
nothing
you know i'm saying so
they come my way with like some life
changing [__]
like
something you doing there k refused
right
i damn there feel like i'd be dumb not
to right
but
besides that i'm i'm steering away with
the independent way the problem is i
want to start my own label and other
type of [__] so you know problem is a
lot of times these labels will come
through and they'll offer you
an advance for a shitty deal and i'm
like yeah i already got that in the bank
i'm doing that right now
cause i'm like we really doing numbers
right
independent upcoming artists i mean your
jewelry would say you're not independent
because that is a massive uh well i
appreciate it it's a lot of hard work
man that's all it is
yeah cause like i'm looking at i'm like
that g what is it that's a six yeah it's
my hood man from six six you know six
war
represent the sixth guy my brother benji
that's where this whole rmc [__] came
from
your brother benji
break down the rmc meaning and like kind
of the reason
for real money counter for anybody who
don't know real money counter yeah real
money counter yeah and like i said it's
from my brother it's from my brother
benji
he uh
he got locked up he had to go away for
some years
i'm sure he's proud though i don't know
hell yeah i talked to him down there
every day you know he
he very proud
i'm just telling like when he when he
see he was the rapper
i never really wanted a rapper like i
always been around it but like i used to
do dibble and dabble with him
but i'm
just like he was the main one you feel
me so like when he got locked up and i
started [__] with this [__] like i
ain't he had no name for the long
because i was just mike right i'm just
like [__] gonna put the rmc on top
over there oh bro down you feel me nice
job and like when i when we started this
[__] bro me or rio
we never expected this [__] to get this
big
what was the for you do you remember
like the moment or the song or the music
video where things started to like
really change for you as far as like
yeah it really it was the first million
views bro when [__] was like
[__]
do you remember when that was like what
song that was like the first time you
guys hit a million
see the crazy thing is
the first video that mia rio ever shot
did a million views that's [__] crazy
so i let you know like this should it's
called loosen nightmares like we're
we're on to something right away
it was it was really mind-blowing bro
what the [__] well because most people
it takes them like
a very long time we will already get
like 10
10 20k 30k that was already big i was
like [__] 20 000 people 30 000 people
but a million money
that's different man
it was like [__] then not even that then
we came with back here back here with
craigs another million plus views like
[__]
we're onto something like this [__]
might yeah
then we dropped dumb and dumber oh that
took us off
that started that started the rocky ship
right there
yeah the joint project
it was up
was there ever any um discussion with uh
dolphin glock about when they did dumb
and dumber because didn't you guys do it
first
yeah we did it first
it was just kind of like i guess maybe
great minds think alike or
chalk it up oh no i feel like bro the
[__] was going so hard they heard that
[__]
that's fair
yeah i always felt like that recipe's
done too i'm a big fan of here
you guys got three of them right three
of them three of them at this point yeah
they was on number two they probably got
three dead i don't know we never know
different spelling though i believe yeah
different spelling
but i mean don't give a rock they helped
us a lot too
with them doing that they helped us a
lot dude and that showed us how like
true with fan base we really would
how much unreleased music do you and rio
have right now
enough
like did you like it you're in a
position where you knew he was going in
so i'm sure like precautions were taken
like look we're gonna [__] make sure
during this time
there's plenty of music to come out
me and rio got some [__] in store for
you
did you guys shoot a bunch of videos too
before we went in like we got to like
run these like run the visuals up and
then maybe just
strategically drop them throughout the
next couple of years honestly
no
and
the reason why is bros doing so much in
the last couple months all right back i
want the focus when even on me and him
no more right
if the [__] was a [__] do as much as
you can
um [__] getting this bread together
making sure you know what i'm saying
just oh it's making making the smartest
decisions in within this time
we're saying i don't say we could have
hey we should have i'm gonna put it like
that but
music was recorded my baby was doing so
much my [__] like literally
i don't know i never seen nobody worth
acting like this [__] bro
that's crazy i'm somebody motivate me
man he damn this show me the way
i'm watching him man and then run around
this [__] like chicken cut up but he
made dog [__] he made sure everything
was taken care of everything was before
yeah you know what i'm saying so that's
when that was down there the main focus
bro get your [__] we gotta get
everything under control before you you
know said
this music [__] timeless with us bro
y'all gonna get music from us until we
decided not to make music no more you
know
that ain't you feeling me what's your
your writing process like because some
people nowadays you know they're just
getting the boot and they'll just kind
of punch in linebacker that's what i'm
doing that's what you're trying to do
all right so there's no writing down
let's go in and figure it out
go in and figure it out
is it harder to learn your verses that
way yeah i mean
sometimes i ain't gonna lie i'm putting
like that sometimes it is like
with me for some reason like
once i hear probably once or two times
i'mma catch most of the verse right
right
cause i feel like when you write it you
probably memorize it a little bit more
oh you for you you definitely do because
i you like when i first started
rapping like even back when i was
wrapping my brother busy like when i
used to do it now i used to write
it got to when i met rio newton when i
stopped writing
it's more efficient to not write if
you're in the studio let me tell you why
i get more done right tell me why i'm
going to tell you why i had to stop
right now
we at e house
you know i'm saying that he had the
studio that's when we started making the
music
and
i was still right at this point the
[__] like [__] pull up a beat
and now i get to write
and these [__] had all son done and
they're waiting on you
they had a whole son done before i'm
doing my verse
so it'd be like
it was it was awesome [__] to where you
got to get with her to get lost
i'm like [__] that y'all like they keep
leaving me out [__] [__] i was just
[__] yeah it's like faster of a
process to do with the punching way
because like you'll have somebody who's
like sitting in the corner with their
pad or their iphone
you know writing and then by the time
that's done the verse and the hook from
someone else listen man verses from
verses from us like we we really be wild
with people bro like
with how fast you lay [__] you can ask
my managers what's the most amount of
songs you recorded in a night
[__]
probably like two three tapes
jesus we listen
it take me six minutes six seven minutes
to do a verse 16
that's crazy
like for real and i'm sure in my life
like yeah you just blessed like that for
some reason and i know you're probably
thinking like yeah you're probably just
saying no like some [__] [__] you're
saying some dope [__] you know what i'm
saying like fans like
well that's gotta be great for the like
i'm on the road hit me dm me for the
feature
go book a studio in a random city and
then you got
every six minutes you're making x amount
of money hey listen it'd be funny though
cause you know like
when people be paying for features and
[__] they're probably getting offended
that you did it so easily they're like
yo i just paid you for that that like
something some [__] be cool but some
of them be like
you know when you when you when you
paying somebody for a fee you down there
want to be in the studio catching five
kick you think we finna be in this [__]
chilling right you think that at least
six
you know unless we doing the video or
something yeah like what are we doing
you want me to hang out for your vlog i
need another [__] no but it'd be [__]
it'd be [__]
[Music]
quicker than me
yeah he's serious that's crazy he's
getting that [__] and you just go i
feel like crazy
um
for you like uh obviously we talked
about the racing [__] what are some of
the other i feel like you're you're you
got a great personality what are the
things you're doing in your free time
besides working on drag cars and [__]
wha what what do your hobbies consist
of i like to travel bro like and i never
noticed that until i was able to travel
right like so every chance i get i like
to just go what's your favorite place
you've been so far it's just here [__]
la what oh there's better places i know
but i ain't made it to you yeah we got
to get you to like cancun or something
you got a passport that's it you got to
get that man i know
that's it listen
i'm on as soon as we get back i barely
got my passport i barely got my passport
like five years ago but i felt like i
finally became an adult
i was like i got a passport right the
thing is it was like it was
[__] always time to get my
passport but [__] the [__] was broke
what the [__] about this 75 bucks and
it's also 75 dollars i get that but i'm
just saying like what the [__] was i
going when i'm like i'm broke 22 or 23
go struggling to make the red 75 bucks a
serious check
[__] passport they got [__] up
[__] i ain't gonna be traveling know
how to [__]
me out yeah you gotta we gotta yeah but
no that's something i definitely i'm on
that soon
yo we gotta stop the interview real
quick to tell you about our partners at
odd socks watch this i bet you i got
socks on right [__] now
oh yeah see them bad boys these are what
we call the odd socks basics the ankles
the ankle socks right go to
oddssocksofficial.com right now
put the website up promo codes bootleg
cab you're gonna save 20 off at checkout
they got so many crazy ass socks we got
twizzlers [__] halloween
uh
i mean these are kind of satanic it just
says demon
they were like let's just do a generic
demon sock
i mean this is kind of like uh
i guess like if you were in the 80s in
miami doing cocaine off of a stripper's
[__]
jaws pepsi i mean listen breaking bad
nickelodeon keep going but what's most
important is odd socks is our family
look if you support odd socks you
support the bootleg cat podcast so go to
bootleg kev well you can go to
bootleghead.com and just check it out
but you can also go to
oddssocksofficial.com
use the promo code bootleg kev and save
20 off at checkout do that [__] right
now all right let's get into the uh
interview that we've already been inside
of but we're going to get back to it
right now what does uh your netflix
history look like what are you watching
on tv man when you're at the crib [__]
uh
i like comedy [__] bro
like for real you know i smoke a lot of
weeds so i just
like funny [__] what's the funny uh
funny show you like
one of the funniest movies to me bro for
some reason and i just watched it
sometime when i get bored bro there
marlon way and [__] it's called sex
tuplets
oh my god that's it that movie is so
funny i guess you gotta be high to
appreciate it man i'll talk about you
guys i think that [__] is terrible man
you gotta watch it funny man you gotta
watch your eye man
that [__] be on me dime man the funniest
character is the one that's kind of slow
man what's dark man that [__] is so
funny
[Music]
air on peacock yeah you ain't good you
ain't 2d yet so
to me it looks like uh kind of like shot
the way all-american shot like super no
it's super dramatic it's definitely
similar to that so i i just it reminds
me of like the cw like dramas when i was
growing up like
i just don't know man i think you should
watch it bro i've heard it's good okay
was you a fresh prince i mean would you
a fresh prince fan of course oh do you
need to watch it bro cause it's she's
that's the other
i'm seeing like the actors and i'm like
it's just like a serious version i mean
i understand why i mean it's i heard
it's good i got to check it out
i'm watching likes
right now i'm watching snowfall i never
could get into this [__] franklin so far
i listened but i never really could get
it i couldn't get into power and i never
really never got into power
i missed out but i like the wire the
wires like that the worry that's always
gonna be a crash and
i only watched the first two seasons of
blacklist but they were good go
that actor is so good he's serious man
and then he's that man the chick
detective and then he doesn't doesn't
she end up being his daughter or
something wild like that that she get
beat me it's [__] crazy and then her
husband in the first season is like the
ops the whole time yeah it the [__] get
wild blacklist was a movie i gotta you
know i never finished blacklist you just
[__] put that up because i because
when i was watching it i was watching it
like when it was like actually on tv
yeah so afterwards
but i think it's on netflix when you get
some time
go go go super good job
you could be in this once they see the
show
it's bingeable for sure definitely
bingeable um you were talking how uh
before the we were on the cameras you
used to do the lean thing you used to be
a heavier guy and you stopped doing lean
you stopped doing lean i stopped oh yeah
ish i stopped oh you see the weight go
down once you stop bro you know what i'm
saying but
i still didn't went that way every once
in a while you know the weight picked
back up
is it was it hard to initially kind of
not really some people say it's like
hard it's like you know you go through
withdrawal i mean you do go through
withdrawals for sure but it's like you
see that you're gonna go through there
regardless yeah you're gonna do that
especially when you've been drinking it
for so long
but
it was just like
[__] that [__] bro then there's too much
come with it bro it's too much cut
laying around this [__] are they
cutting lean with fentanyl yet
i don't know
because i just heard that they're
they're silly i didn't believe this [__]
but they try to tell me that there's
like fentanyl laced weed
which is the craziest [__] i ever said i
don't put it past none of this [__]
these days man these people ain't
getting them smarter technology getting
crazier this [__]
to me weed should be off limits it
should be like the safest thing
for sure like yo i want to smoke weed i
just shouldn't have to worry about it
like i'm not a [__]
yeah
that [__] is crazy the fentanyl [__] is
wild
but yeah laying back on that lane back
on the cup
the cup is you know
people who uh i know people who who like
like you said like
will do it very seldomly
that's what i'm on now that's at the
stage i'm on people who do it every day
though they're [__] i used to be that
dude yeah drink this [__] every day
cause that's how much soda every day and
then too much that's what's really
blowing you up all that [__]
you're drinking [__]
two liter of fantastic
blow up on your ass we got we got little
[__] we've been [__] [__] all day
life until they start drinking lean not
a little with his stomach
is the lean does the lean give you shits
hey
so you have like lean diarrhea
that's what the whip do do all the type
of [__] so stop me [__] that they
should've come out you like water golly
you ever shot your pants
no i have
as how's it grown up
it definitely happened
yeah i forgot where i was i was with my
wife i'm a real [__] though i gotta ask
some close calls but like just straight
up just [__] in my bed no a wet fart
we've all had those
ain't nothing like a wet well
no i did close calls [__] to the point
i'm close to the bathroom
and you feel that [__] damn
they're coming out like i know cook's
out of wet fart look at him like i'm
here though
yeah the
so i got a question for you yeah
what's one of your hobbies that people
don't know about somebody hobbies i love
wrestling straight so i love to watch
wrestling you would have known some [__]
i fell asleep last night watching the
stone cold steve austin love [__] on the
tv
so that's my [__] i love wwe i love
wrestling
i love gambling on sports
you fandueled out
so out here we don't have fanduel i
gotta go i gotta use my bookie [__] i've
never heard of that it's like uh
yeah go to my book you use the promo
code uh bootleg sign up you'll double
your deposit
well my bookie is like a online sports
book for people everywhere you know
because in michigan it's legal right you
could use fanduel in michigan right yeah
you can use fanduel michigan loki's
turns up you guys got the gambling the
recreational weed [__] canada's right
there
yeah
decent food
[Music]
yeah we could say decent food but not
it's not like l.a but i heard that
there's like there what like
because there's like a detroit style dog
right like
we got flintstone county detroit
what is the difference between a flint
style coney and a flint style coney is
hamburger meat man like beef oh yeah on
your hot dog the mustard
troy style coney is chili
and cheese mustard
if someone were to visit flint right
let's say
what would be like the number one place
you'd take them to eat what's the spot
in flint see
real [__] we ain't really got no good
spots but when we big for jobs
so
big john's thinking on you
i think that's some flip [__] for real
you know what i'm saying like
i get used to like i had a couple moms
like from florida
and she fly in and i'll take them there
and they like they listen that's why you
take them
like they love [__]
bro we gotta get some more that big jobs
bro
like [__] i'm so birthed out he's like
i've been having [__] my whole life
when you when uh will ferrell dropped
semi-pro and it was about flint the
flint tropics
shout out
was that like a moment as like a flint
native like we got a movie low-key
it was big
it was a funny [__] movie no it was
funny brazil you ever got punched in the
jungles
is that the nuts
i've been punched in the nuts for sure
y'all remember that off the movie it's
been a while
i just know uh what was the song love
willful acts when
yeah the song and then he fought the
bear
the bear [__] was hilarious
and then they traded a wash machine for
woody harrelson's character
i just remember andre 3000 like was that
like the last andre 3000 movie i feel
like you just stopped acting out of
nowhere no no i think that's great
because he was in the italian job he was
in a few movies but then like i just
stopped doing movies i don't know
um
influence-wise like growing up like who
would you say uh rapper wise was like
your biggest influence is who you were a
biggest fan of just growing up [__] way
wayne gucci
gucci and wayne
busy
shout out to boosie man
yeah
that's a nice trio
i was i was a big white fan though bro
he was just like
he was the jay-z in my ear put it that
way that's that's a fair comparison you
know
he was the jay-z in my ear just me
growing up wayne was on everything like
the new air got a little baby
everywhere you looking
it was wayne in my generation a lot of
people sound like little little babies
right now yeah
it was
a little little way with my ear mm-hmm
before us it was what probably jay-z
here
yeah
but my hair lil wayne was the [__] were
you listening to eminem
[Music]
[Applause]
not like on some
i listen to eminem on the radio you know
he was you know he was everywhere yeah
he was there but i'm not i wasn't really
just going to look up you weren't like
buying that cd and throwing on the white
america
you know
mtv jams oh you know
he all over there she's running that
[__] you know what i'm saying you go you
go bump into his music but me personally
going to search for it nah what about
like the underbelly of uh michigan music
and i by that i mean insane clown posse
and
all that kind of juggalo weird uh
interesting uh see i i really can't get
into that because i never really tapped
into none of that there was like a guy
named ishaam
i heard him i've just recently heard
easter i'm be honest with y'all
they were designated their fans
[Music]
uh are called juggalos
okay
and their fans were designated by the
fbi
as an official gang
so the fbi designated their fans as gang
members
they're for the most part
for the most part not everyone but for
the most part
you know white kids who probably may or
may not do meth
definitely have b.o
and they get these psychopathic like
hatchet man tattoos and
um they got a wild following but like
yeah for a while there they were their
fans were considered like a gang by the
fbi i need to go do my research because
i'm not mistaken i think you pulled that
she pulled that [__] up the other day
some serious [__] yeah they got this
thing called the gathering of the
juggalos which is in ohio every year
and they have like
it's like a free-for-all there's like a
[__] tent there's a drug bridge
it's pretty wild
it's pretty wild they all wear [__]
face paint
but yeah
yeah i really can't speak too much on
that i already know i ain't got no
knowledge of it so man you just came to
juggalo 101 over here at the blue lagoon
now you know yeah he definitely gave me
some look for
um all right so we're getting uh
senior season
uh
anything else
yeah i'm gonna give you all something in
between here i'm gonna try i got a
little ep
working
just know i'm just trying to drive music
randomly man as much as i can much as i
can i'm gonna keep dropping who on the
west coast have you like linked up with
that's like because i feel like there is
a unison between michigan and cali for
some reason i mean it's mostly because
of pax you know but with that being said
first of all rest in peace
the ruler man
yeah that was right
that was a real dude right there
super tapped in i was honored to
met him a couple times we actually got
even got to on the sun together
he put me in rio i want his little tapes
or whatever he got out
yeah i think he might have played us
that song
he's been on the show about she was a sh
he has so many songs with michigan
artists yeah that was that was a big one
you know
[Music]
whoa filthy
filthy of course filthy rich yeah big
bro he
you know said
me and filthy locked here for sure you
guys definitely uh uh
who else on the west coast let me see
that's big like
i mean draco was
rest in peace draco yeah recipe he was
like the biggest one for sure
on the west that
i didn't been blessed to worry you know
that's so dumb being destroyed
does he get you laced up with the come
on man you know i got a lot off a lot of
that [__] yo we got to stop the
interview real quick tell us about uh
i'm gonna tell you about our partners in
my bookie man make sure you go to
mybookie.ag right now
it's gambling season nba playoffs are
about to start what are we doing you can
still get your futures in on the mvp
vote as well you can bet on everything
in my bookie man so look what you got to
do is go to mybookie.com right now
just go to my bookie use the promo code
bootleg when you sign up for a new
account this is important when you sign
up for a new account use that promo code
bootleg and they will give you
a deposit match free money up to a
thousand dollars so if you sign up and
you put 200 bucks in they're gonna give
you another 200 to bet with
thousand they're gonna give you another
thousand to bet with let's go for the
suns all the way just throw all your
money on the phoenix suns
all right and then bet that the warriors
won't make it out of the first [__]
round because jokic is gonna [__]
pound them in their ass probably great
odds on that one anyway mybookie.ag
mybookie just [__] google the [__] my
bookie use the promo code bootleg and
they will match your deposit free money
free money up to a thousand dollars
let's get back to the interview with
trail i see what you did there
i see what you did there
he gave me a bunch of it but it's just
not in my size so i'm like
because they're dickies pants right so
it's like you put dickies on and if they
don't fit you precisely you know maybe a
pair of jeans you could squeeze in if
it's like a size too small dickies just
like
so i'm kind of in like uh i don't know
what you say you know somebody who know
the taylor i mean who am i am i gonna
pull up with a pair of dickies and get
them tailored [__] i will if it makes it
yeah like if they too little you just
[__] but if they're a little bit too big
yeah we no no no they're too little
they're too big
i'm getting fat yeah
i'm getting fat minus the lean it's just
the i'm drinking the soda but i'm not
even getting high on it i got it [__]
up
drinking the soda because i like it
you got [__] soda in there from panda
express right now i just had [__] i had
to get somebody out of here express you
want to talk about bubble guts you go to
panda express you're [__] yourself
right away i'm just going to keep it
real with that [__] which is so nasty oh
it's not great and it'll definitely have
you [__] yourself it was just
awesome it was just on some quick [__]
it was right there panda express
automatic shits um
i would say carl's jr
or hardee's probably is where the uh uh
and then uh jack in the box
jack in the box will have you that's
[__] up disgusting do you have jack in
the box in the michigan
oh yeah we got mcdonald's i mean
everywhere he's got him
carl's jr
no we have mcdonald's that's it we got
burger king
so you just got that's it you don't you
have sonic
we got a sonic sonic is gas i never hate
it you've never had sonic no oh no you
got to get the extra large coney dog put
the fries on top get a [__] giant
cherry limeade
then they come in roller skates your car
you've been missing out this whole time
probably have you had in and out burger
in cala yet
in announcement movie it's definitely
better than mcdonald's yeah it's
definitely better than mcdonald's burger
king might be the like uh
lowest on the totem pole faster for sure
i don't know anyone who goes to bridge
like there's only one thing i eat at
burger i don't even eat that burger can
i get it
either the chicken fries or the rodeo
cheeseburger no i get the original
chicken salad
oh yeah that's the only thing i eat at
burger king if you had to rank fast food
joints
obviously big chains not talking about
like mom and pop places
give me your top five [__]
uh
you gotta put the [__] it's only about
five of them that's big
you gotta put mcdonald's on ain't nobody
[__] with mcdonald's i say this all
the time
i've had arguments with friends because
i say mcdonald's is [__] fire and
they're like it's the worst it is
and i'm like it wouldn't be the biggest
restaurant in the [__] world if the
food wasn't amazing thank you now is it
good for you that's not the conversation
is it good though it's fire it's a mate
and they got their own high c orange
they got their own coke
you see uh like the world was mad when
they discontinued that [__] i was pissed
oh the orange i see what yeah
[Music]
so their coca-cola tastes different than
coke anywhere else
i can believe it because honestly they
got the best orange juice in the world
that's oj
best orange juice there's nothing that
you can point to on a mcdonald's menu
that i'm not like
that's like yo all the breakfast give me
everything
give me the [__] i'll even take a filet
of fish for sure why not fresh with
cheese which give me the whole slice of
cheese though yeah i have the whole
thing
so we got mcdonald's number one hey you
gotta get mcdonald's okay i agree with
you there
there's let's
[Music]
me too i eat chicken quesadillas and i'm
mad they they discontinued the steak
burritos for me and they discontinued
the mexican pizza
yeah i never really [__] with that the
thing about taco bell that i appreciate
is that they're always innovating no for
sure it's like they just hired a bunch
of fools not so friends are actually
good nacho fries are good they all
there's always they're putting fritos
and everything yeah the freeze is always
fire
yeah taco bell is selling it's stellar
fish
taco bell up there you have wendy's in
uh
wendy's i [__] wendy's percy that was
what i was gonna say next so would you
put wendy's above burger king
hell yeah have you ever
had french fries and put them in your
frosty yes fire fire real fat kitchen
i'm a real fat dude that's fire
fire you got it never had
get the frosty
get a fry you gotta dump it what it's
only right
that damn this should be a tradition
yeah all right what's fourth
uh
we need
five you don't you're telling me you
don't have jack in the box no you don't
know we got we got checkers right like
well rallies checkers whatever you want
to put we got rallies though dude we got
both
steak and shake there
no that's in uh arbor hills
okay so you got rallies so i had rallies
and checkers growing up and then when i
lived in florida they had it and it was
like hit or miss
no that [__] is horrible yeah
hey shout out to rick ross i think he
owns like seven of them but that [__]
ain't it that's it
every time you eat that [__] you go into
the bathroom that's straight bubble guts
yeah straight like so would you would
you put burger king above them because i
might i think i put burger king above
around these are checkers cause at least
you get like like i might [__] with
burger king burger king's like at least
old faithful like i know i could get a
whopper or a rodeo cheeseburger or
a chicken sandwich i'll [__] i [__] with
them over
king [__] up because they they started
selling tacos
you see that
i don't understand what they're doing
burger king confused
they confused
jack-in-the-box is low-key a vibe though
it's it's a shame there's no so what we
got we got mcdonald's taco bell wendy's
burger king
and [__] number five you got
see i like i like uh
i feel like we're missing one years man
because we got arby's we got what about
[__] is chick-fil-a in the in the is it
no no
no that's the arbor hills too we got
[__] little caesars is not fast food
bro
yeah
little caesars
i mean little caesars is like the most
popeyes we got herbies
arby's
fire i put arby's
i would put arby's above
burger king for sure because arby's is
like yeah yeah they sliders fire sliders
yeah them sliders they're cheap you get
the ham and cheese you get the cheesy
roast beef
[__] curly fries without then like
arby sauce that arby sauce
there we go we got our five arby's is
for burger king five yeah i like that i
respect that list yeah
that's a nice list right there that's
about the best you're gonna get when you
go to mcdonald's though what is your
go-to order
me
i gotta get a mcchicken with cheese see
look spicy mcchicken right
i like them too okay
but meat chicken with cheese
you gotta get a mcdouble see me i like
bacon so i get a bacon mcdouble
big double yeah
nuggets i usually get the number nine
it's the two two cheeseburgers
i get extra large fries i like to stuff
them with fries the burgers with fries
right
and then i do the spicy mcchicken on the
side and i'm a frappe man though i love
them they got great coffee they're
coffee rival starbucks
what caramel frappe fire mm-hmm
yeah they got good coffee at mcdonald's
okay i don't know what about on the
breakfast side just you just keep in the
basics
they got mcgriddles this ain't all at
once but i'm just saying like this is
the main three things i eat
i eat the sausage burritos oh yeah with
that [__] picante chunky salsa the
sausage burrito did not eat the uh
what's the sausage mcmuffin
gotta get that with cheese
and then i do the the
sausage mcgriddle with cheese
is the one
that [__] right there and then you
gotta take half of the ass brown and
smack it on there oh
my grill jelly i wanna know who who
invented the mcgriddle who said we're to
make the buns taste like their syrup
damn they was smarty [__] shout out to
my grills man love mcgregor sure well
there it is man some good fat boy talk
to end the show
go uh go follow this guy it's just rmc
mike yeah rlc underscore mike on
instagram man with his rmc might
everywhere look that [__] about anything
all social media all right have you uh
have you launched your own weed [__] out
in michigan yet i feel like that would
that would be like are you gonna launch
your own strain out in uh in in michigan
yet it's coming it's coming it's
definitely coming there it is
definitely look out for this strand and
look out for the 5.0 drag racing card
right around zero black mamba black
mamba yeah shout out to kobe yeah shout
out to you i know you have the pistons
jersey on your album cover but are you a
pistons fan
i'm gonna always be a pistons fan shout
out to kate cunningham you got to you
got to be
you know bad boys what's the [__] yeah
like nowadays
yeah but they got some promise kate
cunningham
yeah we know the the the all-star team
we had we had our all-star team back
there and even uh even you know they
just got to rebuild missy the crazy
thing is bro
i really don't even watch
the nba no more bro what do you watch
like sports wise you're watching [__]
nascar did you like cars or no but i
have been to a nascar race before i
heard they're fun it is and it's loud
and [__] yeah they used to give out free
cigarettes at those oh [__]
when kobe
when that [__] happened to call comey
bro i just
lost all for basketball that's how big
of a fan i was of course
what about football i know i ain't gonna
take nothing away from lebron you know
he did his thing but kobe would have
never not made the playoffs
that's not true actually [__] that
that's not that's it in his prime well i
guess he get a little older oh you give
it to him lebron's been in the league
y'all got a stag team though bro just
don't say y'all i'm a sons fan i gotta
get it but they got a stacked team how
the [__] y'all didn't make the playoffs
just just listen though
kobe didn't make the playoffs in his
career as well he did but
[__] that i'm a kobe man shout out to
kobe
rest in peace rest in peace money he's
up there with jordan yeah there you go
there we go right there you gotta put
lebron up there too though you gotta go
oh for sure you gotta give him his
problem that [__] is some serious he's
a specimen man 19 years in he still
looks like [__] yeah like it was
oh what does that feel yeah man what is
he doing he spends a million dollars a
year on his body
[__]
so either there's that
that's all you need to know there it is
man well listen i appreciate you pulling
up i appreciate you having me there it
is bullet cat podcast rmc mike yes sir
sheesh